ispirate miei amici cari ed espirate
assumere questa posizione toccate l'osso
col vostro medio il vostro pollice e
quel posto l'altro medio e cos'altro
pollice che fate siamo su uomo yoga che
sarebbe un gioco di di yoga s'era capito
spacebar per stare sugo la schiena
ragazzi sulla schiena treaty quando
state guardare di ritocco la schiena
dritta non come me che quando sono
seduto a fare i video sono seduto così
con le ginocchia non così non così
stretti con la schiena schiacciate st
barra spaziatrice e mettete vista
colonna dritta maledizione seguite
attentamente le lezioni di yoga del
maestro famiglie perfetto freedom fa a
edolo copiarmi le cose va bene eccolo
proprio lui
e vabbè aiuto non so non capisco allora
credo che io debba alzare una mano della
gamba destra quindi n
però allo stesso tempo devo abbassare la
testa come la bassa da rocca è giusto è
giusto guardalo martalò con la in alto
la in alto now madonna no ragazzi è
impossibile ma non posso fare sta roba
io non si può
ff no non f scherzavo dall'altra parte
santo iddio ok alza l'altra gamba alza
l'altra gamba ma io sto premendo il
tasto braccia non alza sai volanti sto
volando con lo yoga ragazzi volante ve
lo dico io
non funziona benissimo non so come
faccia raggiungere questa posizione non
sono anche se qualcuno ha fatto sto
gioco qui non gli possono copiare le
tecniche non c'è modo di aiuto è un cucù
hope in questo gioco porca vacca dai è
giusto è giusto
no aspetta vii affetto ok e adesso la m
è giusto è giusto temi tutti risulti è
bravo bravo bravissimo è giusto dai
molla cosa vuoi più di così e
giustissimo è giustissimo
ecco guarda già facciamo sto male giando
ma pian piano che molleggio già sto
facendo da ragazzi esatto proprio lui ci
ho messo un ora per farlo per ragazzi
l'obiettivo è mentre allora appoggiate
il telefono per terra guardate questo
video sul telefono al computer non
quello che volete
prendete le distanze mettete alto il
volume e fate esattamente quello che
vedete ok dovete fare tutte le mosse che
vedete la mucca calma la colla posa
della mucca calma quella la mucca calma
va bene non so come è fatta mettere un
piede così però primo e secondo si è
girato dall'altra parte quindi devo
proprio lo girarmi bene ora mi sono
spostato ufficialmente però non so come
ritornare come prima cesto brin piccolo
problema
ok allora li facciamo quello che abbiamo
fatto prima che non so come bravo bravo
bravo perfetto devi devi devi sollevare
la brevità sembravo proprio lui la i lay
line dove la mettiamo un bravissimo a
testa ok
ma ragazzi ma io sono fatto per questo
gioco cosa devo fare qua qua ra subito
da faccio questa strana tattica che la
scuola stavo sempre se tutto così quindi
non dovrebbe essere un problema
f 3 mm si pieghi l'abbraccio bravissimo
non è proprio la stessa cosa ma fa
niente
ci siete ragazzi state mou lando le mie
mosse bellissime i quali vedono fatto
esattamente quello che perché fa che fa
sto facendo io non anche lo stesso
taglio di capelli vi dovete fare i saw
tizio allora devi allungare la gamba
allunga la gamba si allunga la gamba la
gamba giu l'altra gamba l'ala quella
quella lì bravo bravo e la li devi
allungare devi allungarla degli stand i
segni ragazzi nella gamba stendi la
gamba per stessa eni la gamma tutta
tutta la gamba giù tutta la gamba stemmi
la gente guarda stendi la gamba ma ciò
dei problemi
eccolo bravo no giù giù giù giù la gamba
giu la gamba giu la gamba sono
incastrato in una posizione un po sono
in casa puoi mettere giù la gamba per
cortesia
no non la mette giù pavelec io posso
volare in questo gioco ma come è
possibile
nn premi nnn ok
l'obiettivo sarebbe ma che cosa sta
succedendo va bene non è proprio quello
devo riuscire a cadere con le gambe
divaricate ace goku ha sviluppato
l'abilità del volo così e non solo visto
madonna è bravo bravo per terra però fa
dio c'è un modo per riuscire a
meraviglioso ok ci siamo ci siamo ce
l'ho fatta hai fatto tutte le cose in
523 seconda come è finito qua era
l'ultima davis hanno spaccato il
deretano penso fossero molto di più
bello però molto carino prima vedere i
cupi come ciò che abbiamo un sacco di
tempo che non lo faccio passano gli anni
ma io comunque sia continua a fare
questa cosa penso che sia anche motivato
nel senso che il genio che ha creato sta
roba è lo stesso che ha creato and
getting over infatti due domande me le
farei io reputo quest'uomo bennett body
creator di sta roba
il miglior creatore videogiochi della
storia perché lui con poco riesce a fare
delle cose incredibili ad esempio ha
fatto getting over it no che un gioco
incredibile se ci pensate chi è che
pensa di mettere un pelato dentro una
pentola una roba pazzesca però la roba
che a me viene in mente è la seguente
scusami ma siccome getting avete
difficile consegnarlo come gioco ma non
tanto farlo ho fatto 35 metri non è male
ve lo assicuro è difficile avere l'idea
di katyn guarita ma non tanto il creato
perché alla fine devi creare un ambiente
e poi farci farlo scalare ad un uomo
pentono ok quindi ecco è quello
difficile ma la mia domanda quella che
mi sorge veramente spontanea è perché
non ha fatto getting over it due in
tempo zero visto che ha venduto la
madonna ma che getting over it ha
venduto un miliardo e mezzo di copie
fossi stato io saremo già getting over
it 8 come minimo perché veramente ne
avrei fatti mille perché non hai fatto
ancora altri getting over it bennett
body camon lei coders getting o brics
weekend bestemmie in the game
non riesco a concepire questa cosa
comunque noi giochiamo c per l'ennesima
volta google piva di volere se a
scrivere al 100 metri è impossibile ci
sono riuscito solo una volta nella mia
vita quasi ma non sono arrivato a 168 di
po 75 prima ho fatto 35 vi assicuro che
è un miracolo non so come ho fatto non
ci arriverò mai più è una volta che
prendi via po più semplice però bisogna
prendere il via e vi assicuro che il
difficile è proprio quello però c'è chi
continua con le ginocchia non so come
sia possibile però io c'è una tattica
che mi ha sempre un po funzionato
ma non del tutto che quella che stava
usando prima però devo devo assumere un
un'armonia nei movimenti per fare quello
che stavo facendo prima cosa che non mi
riesce proprio sempre con cui io vi dico
ragazzi che quando ero a scuola che ci
avevamo le lezioni di informatica mi
portavo la chiavetta e quanto ero malato
la infilavo nel computer di informatica
e giocava questo ti giocavamo a qualcosa
con la chiavetta ci infilavamo nella
chiavetta i giochini stupidi e il
giocavamo tipo di giocava questo è happy
wisco non devo scuola giuro per forza
essi ciò che ci vuole flash player no e
io non c'è l'ex player perché ovviamente
nei computer di scuola da van
disattivato per evitare che gli studenti
giocassero la riportava la chiavetta con
mozilla portatile dentro che ci aveva il
flash player e giocava sta roba era
veramente incredibile 17 dai 20 metri
dai vari good 26 23
va bene dai posso diminuire il mio
obiettivo a 50 perché è veramente
impossibile cioè non so se vi di fitch è
questo che ti ngo no penso che questo
passiamo corapi kipseli getting over it
di alcuni punti bisogna trovare quel
modo che io ancora non ho trovato e ho
anche visto dei tutorial su come andare
avanti ma vi assicuro che è proprio
difficile ragazzi la mia debole mente si
sta distruggendo vide che può andare
bene così da almeno a battere il mio
record dell'inizio da almeno 35
maledizione che ho fatto subito e poi
non sono uscito di abbatterlo
maledizione ho fatto una rana
incredibile prima dai forza
perfetto siamo a metà
dai
bellissimo 30 dai eccolo e la supera
verso 50 attenzione 40 per dio
e vabbè record imbattibile
l'ho calciato questo no ragazzi non sono
arrivato cosi lontano fermi l'ho
calciato
no no no no no no no no no no no no
58 raga ho superato l'ostacolo non ho
mai superato l'ostacolo l'ho calciato
via fortissimo con forse non avevo mai
superato l'ostacolo 58 tantissimo raga
visti da far di meglio comunque magari
questo era video di oggi so che siete
contenti delle quali ti content che
porto sul mio canale soprattutto
nell'ambito di gaming però videogiochi
seri giochiamo la mattina il martedì il
giovedì e la domenica con nichi box il
demone ling ling quindi seguiteci anche
abbonatevi ad un canale che c'è stato il
tasto qua sotto e c'è anche il tasto
campanella che è molto importante anche
come il tasto iscriviti quindi
schiacciate tutte e tre e non ci vediamo
come sempre al prossimo video per
ragazzi
[Musica]